Oh 10 9 location I have a teammate here
they asked me where I was from and I
said Canada New Jersey he said man I
feel bad for you when I was young I
didn't realize that what I was seeing
was Pat just a few years ago in North
Camden we wouldn't be able to see any
kids playing around outside because they
would be in danger of exchanging gunfire
and never really phased me growing up
cuz I just thought like it's just how
that's how neighborhoods look every 72
hours you see a shooting alarmingly
Camden's murder rate has more than
doubled this year compared to last it
wasn't until my cousin Jumeirah died
that realized Camden was dangerous I
know what to think
I was like I mean I hope he's all right
and people got shot at a time I still
live maybe he's all right
it wasn't like he was somebody I didn't
didn't have the opportunities he was a
football player is being recruited by
multiple schools it was just then I was
like wow this isn't this isn't really
the place for us like we have to get out
of here four or five months later got
the opportunity to come here I didn't
want to leave my mom my family in Camden
my mom decided like I'll just take a
visit down there see what things are
like it was so nice there was nothing
that like looked bad you know I know I
could go to the beach whenever I wanted
the facilities the buildings when I got
my tour I was like it's a nice locker
room it's like wow this opportunity came
and I felt like those if I passed it up
I was just I was being a fool
I'm just really gonna laugh from
football I mean my game is that at a
point I never thought it'd be yet
really open my eyes it's like a lot of
different things that are out there in
the world when I'm here so long and I'm
not home I'm able to realize how much
trouble is actually back at home
to be one of those guys as opportunity
to come back and make an impact I
definitely will
I'm gonna do that if if I don't go to
NFL I'll do that even if I can't play
football anymore I was going to come
back and try to help people
that's good